what's going on everyone axle beats here
for anime uproar and as we know devil
fruits are some of the most exciting and
crazy elements in the one piece world
and our straw hats have quite a few as
it is but it makes me wonder if all of
the crew was to get devil fruits and the
ones who have devil fruits got new ones
which would they get so today we're
going to be talking about all the devil
fruits that they currently have and then
seeing what other devil fruits I think
might fit if they had to get new ones
you know the drill if you enjoy this one
piece content and you want to see more
remember to leave a like down below and
if you're new to anime uproar remember
to subscribe to the channel so that you
don't miss any of our future videos but
before we get into the incredibly
versatile thing that is devil fruits
let's first talk about the sponsor of
today's video the single most versatile
web browser available Opera GX Opera GX
is a highly customizable browser that
allows you to show off your personality
and interest through the way you use the
internet from picking themes that fit
you best to animated wallpapers like
this gorgeous animated shinobu kocho one
that could be set up in seconds Opera GX
also brings you your favorite media in a
more accessible way than ever allowing
you to pop out videos in floating
adjustable windows and connect to
Spotify Apple music and YouTube music
and automatically pauses them when you
start using other video or Music These
are particularly useful features for me
so I can go on scripting and editing
seamlessly as I pull up the episodes
that we're talking about without even
needing to close everything else I'm
using on top of that switching to Opera
GX has never been easier as you can
import everything from your bookmarks to
your browsing history with just a few
clicks not to mention Opera GX is also a
great way to keep up to date with our
Channel as well as by using the link in
the description you'll also be able to
see the most recent uploads right on
your main page so a massive thank you to
Opera GX for sponsoring this video be
sure to use my link down below to
download Opera GX today so when it comes
to adding or swapping fruits we need to
set some rules firstly let's assume that
Brooke is alive and well today so that
he doesn't need the yomiyomi Nomi second
we gotta make Chopper a human so that he
doesn't need the heat oh hitonomi then
of course Nico Robin loses her Hana
Luffy loses the Nika and finally I'm
either going to use existing or imagined
devil fruits depending on what I think
fits the character best this isn't going
to be based on Purely power but I'm
gonna try and Link it to the characters
traits personality things like that that
will make the fruit shine as the
character uses it with that said now
that everyone is a blank sheet we can
assign new Devil fruits to the straw hat
crew Luffy's original Fruit is of course
the gun gum fruit which turned his body
into rubber later we found out that it
was actually the mythical sun god Nika
fruit which enables him to turn his
imagination into reality once it became
awakened the gum gum fruit has always
allowed Luffy to be resistant to any
blunt force attacks this includes things
like bullets punches or falling from
Heights they're all things that he can
literally bounce back from at the same
time he is still vulnerable to slashes
or piercing attacks making swordsman a
pretty big threat for him if he's not
careful of course Luffy can always
stretch and the majority of his attacks
at base form come from this slingshot
like action that his fruit allows for
once Luffy incorporates his own take on
the cp9s rokushiki he is able to enter
second gear to do this he increases his
blood flow throughout his body and it
gives him a massive power boost to both
his speed and strength opening up a
whole new series of attacks like jet
pistol gear third instead sees Luffy
blowing into his arms to inflate his
bones and creating massive limbs to
attack with in gear 4 Luffy covers parts
of his body with Armament hockey and
enters three different forms bounceman
is a buff gorilla-like form that works
more on a spring-like function for its
attacks rather than the normal elastic
Luffy will pull his fists into
themselves until the pressure builds up
and they launch back out almost like
those old popper toys we used to play
with bounce man also lets Luffy Fly for
a little bit using this action to propel
himself forward through his legs while
he's in the air tank man is the ultimate
defensive form that makes Luffy very
hard to injure he can't really do a lot
while he's in this form he just kind of
sits there and eats until his enemy is
worn out snake man is the final gear 4
form and it trades defense for Speed
allowing Luffy to make long-ranged
attacks that increase in velocity and
power the further the punches fly and
that leads us to the gum gum fruits
Awakening with gear 5. Luffy's power is
only limited by his imagination in this
form he can grow to be a giant grab
lightning curl up the ground and bounce
things off of it and basically he turns
on Looney Tunes rules I am super excited
to see what comes from this fruit but
for now we just need to accept that the
possibilities seem to be endless on top
of all that this form also brings with
it the Return Of Joy boy which will
undoubtedly be incredibly important as
the story approaches its end now on to
the big question what would I swap this
with and I'm gonna be honest we're
starting off with a character who is
definitely the most difficult to give a
new fruit to and this is for a few
reasons firstly this is a fruit that
kind of is an integral part of the plot
the whole Luffy being a Reincarnation of
Joy boy is pretty important secondly the
fruit really fits well with Luffy's
personality Luffy is a very flexible
person who always bounces back whenever
he gets knocked down so I would want to
choose a fruit that kinda has a special
feeling to it while also being very fun
I'd want Luffy to be able to keep his
sense of motion and energy while still
having a good feeling of stature
Melanie's spring fruit was an option
that kind of keeps the motion but I
think it's too similar to the original
to really make this interesting another
option was Bello Betty's pump pump fruit
which could be in line with luki's
ability to inspire others instead though
I decided that we'd actually have to
make our own devil fruit for this one
with the saru sarunomi or the monkey
monkey fruit at its core this fruit
would allow Luffy to still move and
fight in interesting and dynamic ways
all while still being his fun-loving
self plus as chimps tend to be pretty
strong it could even give him a
significant power boost on top of that
we could add a tale to him similar to
the one that young Goku had as well
which might add to that fun feeling I
know this is kind of surface level as
his name is literally Monkey D Luffy but
I think that we could boost it up a bit
by making it a mythical Zone rather than
a basic one kinda like the Nikka fruit
already is so rather than the monkey
monkey fruit we'd have the monkey monkey
fruit model San Wukong embodying the
character from Journey to the West and
at the same time paying homage to Dragon
Ball which inspired one piece so heavily
the Wukong fruit would give Luffy a ton
of new abilities the original Wukong was
strong enough to lift two mountains
while running at the speed of a meteor
and while I don't think that's something
we should allow Luffy to do I think Big
Boost to strength and speed is totally
fair he also had access to 72 Earthly
Transformations which could allow Luffy
to turn into this free-flowing fighter
who could become anything mid-attack
imagine he comes in for a punch and his
body turns into a gorilla only to jump
above his enemy as a kangaroo and drop
onto them as an elephant it could be the
ultimate zone fruit and he would have a
ton of other abilities too to quote
Wukong himself I know how to conceal
myself and vanish I can make spells and
end them I can reach the sky and find my
way to Earth I can travel Under the Sun
or the moon without leaving a shadow or
move through metal and stone freely I
cannot be drowned or burned and there is
nowhere I cannot go I think that the
idea of imagination and freedom that is
so core to Luffy could definitely be
shown through this fruit and while the
idea to fight with a giant stick and a
flying cloud are tempting I think that
might be too similar to Goku so I'm
probably going to avoid them all in all
I think this is a great option for Luffy
to have as an alternate fruit Zorro on
the other hand I think is much more
straightforward we want something to do
with swords blades Buddhism or demons I
think that the obvious one to go for is
Mr one's dice dice fruit turning him
into a living blade and trust me I would
be super tempted to make it some kind of
Akuma mythical fruit but since we just
gave one to Luffy I think that'd be kind
of cheating I can't just make everyone a
mythical devil fruit you know another
option could be baby five's arms fruit
and I mean it could be cool to see Zoro
incorporate a whole host of weapons into
his attacks firing off guns between the
slashes of his swords we could also go
with Eric's sickle sickle fruit to make
his sword swings into long range slices
but I think the fruit that I'm actually
gonna go with is buggies Chop Chop fruit
this fruit would allow Zoro to bring his
three sword style to an entirely new
level by detaching his head and hands to
produce more wild and ranged attacks I'm
gonna be honest though one factor that I
don't particularly really like with this
and you might think it's a good idea is
the fact that the fruit would make Zoro
immune to other blades the reason I
dislike this is it kind of gives Zorro
too easy a Time against other Swordsmen
a big part of his character is facing
adversity and overcoming it and this
kind of feels like a cheat code to me
but whether or not that makes the fruit
a good match is completely up to you if
you don't like this one I do think the
dice dice fruit is probably the best
option Usopp is another character that
could have gone a lot of ways a sniping
related fruit a fruit which allows him
to run away or Escape or a fruit that
ties into telling lies or creating
Illusions and there were plenty of
options but I think the one that best
fits comes from Film Z with binz's grow
grow fruit as we've seen Usopp grow and
develop as a character he's moved away
from a lot of the tricks that he used to
play and has instead began to work
towards becoming a brave Warrior of the
sea through his use of Pop greens as
such the grogro fruit could be
devastatingly powerful this fruit would
allow usop to free really control and
manipulate his pop greens however he
wanted he could make them bigger decide
how they move force them to capture
enemies or protect his allies it
basically takes all the versatility and
power of the pop greens and makes them
exponentially higher onto Sanji and I'm
guessing this will be the controversial
one now what he's not going to get is
the clear clear fruit to become
invisible the glare glare fruit to see
through clothing or the pet pet fruit to
well you get the idea there's not going
to be anything pervy here to me there
were really three options when it came
to Sanji firstly Bellamy's spring fruit
imagine the Boost that this could give
to sanji's kicks and jumps he'd be even
more of an absolute monster when it came
to putting out damage than he already is
second option is frozen's cook cook
fruit and I may have mispronounced that
name it's a difficult one for me to say
but this fruit would allow Sanji to turn
anything into food which is pretty
straightforward as to why a chef might
be able to make good use of that fruit
that said it isn't exactly the most
exciting devil fruit but I'd be
interested to see if Sanji could manage
to make some creative uses for it
especially on the battlefield the fruit
that I actually decided on for Sanji is
aces or the flame flame fruit the fire
abilities that this could provide would
couple pretty well with sanji's Diablo
Jean and on top of that we could add
some jet-like propulsion to his kicks or
jumps similar to the effect of the
spring spring fruit would have had this
would also give him access to flames and
heat and fits with the idea of him being
a chef and cooking things as well I know
people probably won't like the idea of
Sanji getting Ace's fruit but I think it
fits most aspects of his character
really well and even thematically Flames
are supposed to be about passion and
that's like kind of sanji's big thing on
to Nami though and we have a few traits
that we can play off we have Nami being
a cat burglar loving money using her
femininity as well as being a navigator
and someone who's proficient in reading
the weather there are definitely plenty
of choices here if this was much earlier
in the series I think the clear clear
fruit could have been really cool for
allowing Nami to sneak around invisibly
which could definitely have been a very
cool idea as far as loving money the
gold gold fruit is an option but I don't
really think it fits her much so we can
just move past that one what would be a
very interesting option though is BOA
Hancock's love love fruit just like boa
Nami often uses her sexuality to her
advantage and even for Laughs from time
to time with things like the happiness
punch it's a choice that I think could
have been very fun but I think for Nami
the best option would be for her to
focus on weather and navigation based
abilities Monet's snow fruit or annel's
Rumble Rumble fruit are both pretty
decent options maybe like a week weaker
version or a non-lokia version of the
rumble Rumble fruit might have been a
better option but I think that dragon's
fruit or a toned down version of it
would probably be the best choice
obviously we don't know everything about
this fruit but we do know that it has
something to do with the wind it doesn't
need to be as drastically powerful as
dragons but I think manipulating the
wind or airflow could definitely make
her an even better Navigator and help
her to control weather even more than
she already does Chopper's devil fruit
is the hito hitonomi or the human human
fruit this is a Zone fruit which gives
him access to a large almost yeti-like
human form and a hybrid form that is
small and cuddly which is his most
common form to be in the fruit gives
Chopper human level intelligence and
allows him to speak as well even
becoming smart enough to invent the
rumble ball which gave him access to
several new forms including jumping
point guard Point Arm Point and Horn
Point Each of which giving a boost to
one specific aspect of Shoppers fighting
style originally if he ate three Rumble
balls in too short of a time frame he
would lose control of his fruit and
enter the rampaging monster point where
he lost all sense of self and could not
recognize Friend or Foe Post Time skip
Chopper stops using arm and jumping
point and replaces them with Kung Fu
point which is kind of like a hybrid of
both he also only needs one Rumble ball
to access monster point and gains
control of it finally with the help of
Caesar Clown he's able to keep this form
active for 30 minutes but reverts to a
baby-like state once it wears off
Chopper was kind of a strange one so
much of his character comes from him
having been a reindeer who became a
human so removing that aspect was a bit
weird I could cop out and say he gets
the reindeer Zone fruit but that's super
boring one option could be offices
whisper whisper fruit which allowed them
to speak to animals this kind of Keeps
The Animal theme in play which I think
is a pretty good way of doing things but
there's also the doctor wrote and I
don't want him to have laws of a off
they know me I don't think think that
suits Chopper at all at least the room
aspect of it is very strange so maybe
like Nami we could give him a
watered-down version of someone else's
powerful fruit a medic medic fruit or a
nurse nurse fruit which wouldn't give
him any of the room abilities but would
specifically boost up the healing
capabilities of Law's fruit between that
and the whisper whisper I think we could
have some pretty good choices for
Chopper Robin was probably the one I was
most excited for on this list and that's
for a few reasons while I love the Hana
hananomi or the bloom bloom fruit that
she already has it doesn't exactly
supplement her character this fruit
allows her to sprout body parts on any
nearby surface from walls to people's
backs as long as it's solid she can
Sprout hands legs or even an entire
clone of herself there Robin can also
make amalgams of her limbs to produce
giant forms of them or to give herself
wings that allow her to fly for a few
moments something that I really liked
that was introduced Post Time skipped is
that she can even Infuse these attacks
with the basics of Fishman karate which
she learned while she was with the
revolutionaries finally Robin's newest
ability was shown off in her fight with
black Maria we see her using demon
blooming an attack where she grows a
giant upper body with extra parts like
wings fangs and horns to look like a
devil and that part is pretty fitting
considering the devil child epithet but
like I said the fruit as a whole just
doesn't fit in super thematically with
Robin outside of the idea of keeping
people at arm's length which to her has
a whole new meaning so what other
aspects of her character could we focus
on we have her being a spy and an
assassin but I think the better option
was to focus on her being an
archaeologist the first thing I thought
about was something like the opposite of
Lady toki's time time fruit but rather
than jumping ahead Robin would be able
to jump backwards in time and still not
be able to return this would allow Robin
to go back and help leave messages for
the future about the void Century or
help to prevent the void Sentry
altogether but this would also come at
the expense of leaving her friends in
the present and overall I just didn't
feel super good about this one so
instead I came to aim's reverse reverse
fruit this fruit allowed into de-age
things back 12 years that being people
or inanimate objects and of course this
could be done over and over again until
things were in their former glory or
until they ceased to exist so while this
could be used in really interesting ways
in a fight I think using it on ancient
artifacts or relics to return them to
better condition would be a really cool
thing to see Robin be able to do imagine
seeing her go through the ruins of old
wano or Sky Pia or wherever else and
start renewing all the broken and
ancient things that they found all while
still being very in line with her
character for Frankie I wanted a fruit
that revolved around machinery and metal
both of these options bringing us to
kids devil fruit or Douglas bullets
Clank Clank fruit I don't think that I'd
want Frankie to have access to Blitz
awakened fruit I think that's a bit too
much but I do like the idea of Frankie
being able to manipulate the Machinery
around him and create new inventions on
the Fly we've seen him make staircases
into the sky Bridges and giant nunchucks
just from the scraps lying around but
imagine how much he'd be able to do if
he had these devil fruits in the mix the
access to the parts and the utility that
these would offer would just let him
make even more insane and dynamic
creations and all of that without even
mentioning just the flat fighting
ability that these fruits would offer
remember we don't have Luffy's gear
third anymore so Frankie with giant
punches made of metal or machinery would
be very cool to fill in that Gap onto
Brook the yomi yomi Nomi gives Brooke a
second life once he dies at first it
seemed like that was all that would
happen however as he becomes more
accustomed to the fruit he's able to
call forth the chill of the underworld
and incorporate some Icy abilities into
his repertoire on top of that he learns
to manipulate souls in general this
means that he can force his own soul out
of his body and allow its ghostly form
to travel freely even through walls
making it a great espion knowledge tool
it also means he has the ability to
dominate weaker Souls like with big
mom's homies as they're just fragments
of her own soul it's a fruit that's very
core to Brooke's identity but if we were
to assume that he was fully Alive what
other fruits could fit better with
Brooke we have the idea of music and he
no longer needs a second life so on the
note of Music we have a Pooh's tone tone
fruit and it's what I first went to but
I think it just feels kind of off apu's
fruit is all about sound effects rather
than the music itself and as a result it
just doesn't sit quite right for Brook
in my head instead we're going to make
up a new fruit which uses music we could
call it the score score fruit or the
note note fruit this would boost the
effects of his music that causes status
conditions like lullabies or whatever
else while also turning the notes and
scores that he plays into physical
things and possibly carrying different
effects with them sad songs could have
an effect similar to perona's ghosts
happy music could motivate people and
the tempo that he plays could have an
effect on the speed of those who hear it
there's a lot of Versatility that a
fruit like this could offer especially
in a musician as wide-ranged and
talented as Brooke and on to our final
straw hat Jean Bae and uh we have
officially come to an issue chinbei
isn't just a fish man he is the fish man
and more so than any other fish man he
benefits from water and that leaves him
in a pretty strange space if he was to
eat a devil fruit and lose his ability
to swim if I had to give him one though
I think there are two that could
possibly work firstly Senor Pink's swim
swim fruit which will allow him to swim
through land I think it could also be
interesting if it allowed him to
incorporate the effects of his Fishman
karate on the land he swims through as
well allowing him to kind of Bend and
freely manipulate it like he does for
water but I guess that would depend on
the specifics of his fruit a more
straightforward option and the one that
I think is a little bit of a better fit
would be be aruges devil fruit imagine
jinbei becoming this massive hulked out
version of himself mid-fight just this
ultimate brawler and as we've seen he
can still manipulate water from outside
of it so he would still freely be able
to use the water as a weapon just as he
already does of course we also have our
honorary straw hats as well beefy could
definitely benefit from Bello Betty's
pumpkin fruit to inspire those around
her as the leader of a Nation this is
kind of the perfect fruit especially
when it comes to a nation that recently
went through Civil War or a desert
nation that inherently has to overcome
adversity and the dangers of day-to-day
life and with Yamato and before we get
those comments I'm still in denial let
me have this Yamato's own fruit is the
Inu Inu Nomi mythical motto okuchi no
makami this is based on the now extinct
Japanese gray wolf and as with all zones
this fruit offers two new forms for
Yamato firstly a wolf-like form and
second being this hybrid wolf human form
both of which are incredibly powerful
these forms give the Yamato access to
fangs Claws and a pretty massive boost
to her strength and speed on top of that
as it's a mythical Zone it also gives
her a special ability in this case being
able to produce ice or even shoot blasts
of it through her mouth it's an
incredibly cool fruit but I do think I
have some interesting alternative ideas
Yamato lived her life In Chains held
captive under kaido so I think taking
that struggle and turning it into her
strength would be very poetic in a
beautiful way giving Yamato hira's cage
cage fruits or mad Treasures chain chain
fruit could be a genuinely cool way to
turn her past trauma into a physically
manifested strength locking her
opponents down like she had been for so
long and bolstering her own strength to
overcome them I already really love the
fruit that Yamato has so it was kind of
hard to think of a new one for her but
if she had to get something else I think
that these could be really interesting
ones for her to deal with and that's all
of them this was a surprisingly
difficult list to make but I think that
the fruits we came up with were very
thematically fitting at the very least
while still being very fun and exciting
let me know what you guys think though
do you like my choices for alternate
fruits or do you think that other fruits
could have fit better with these
characters or do you prefer the
originals and if so which original Fruit
is your favorite tell us what you think
and while you're down there remember to
leave a like to show support in this
video and to tell us that you want more
one-piece content you can also subscribe
to the channel so you make sure you
never miss any of the great content
coming your way if you're looking to
support me personally you can always
check out my own channel axle beats I
have a Dragon Ball video coming out
fairly soon and of course a massive
thank you to Opera GX for sponsoring
this video be sure to check them out in
the description down below but for now
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time remember to stay
excellent